Ciao tesoro come posso aiutarti Voglio
un kit per suture No amore mi sa che ha
svelato negozio però eh No cioè io al
mattino posso venderti questo fantastico
completino per Capodanno
un chiaro esempio di oggettivazione
femminile per lo sguardo maschile
soffocheresti un villaggio con tutto il
profumo che ti spruzzi Amore ma potevi
dirlo prima vuoi un profumo dolciastro
quasi in auto al mondo Abbiamo anche
quello col naso abbondo mi è quasi
tentata Ma no ti ho detto che mi serve
solo un kit per sutura ma la tua è
proprio un'ossessione eh preferiresti
che avessi un'ossessione per i
microscopici completini intimi che vendi
amore non conquisterai mai nessun
ragazzo senza questo completino è
proprio quello il programma
[Musica]
mercoledì tesoro Che bello rivederti Sei
sempre più pallida Grazie e comunque chi
sei Ma come chi sono Sei sempre la
solita simpaticona la vedo sono Babbo
Natale ovviamente non ricordavo fossi
donna sbarbata e vestirsi come una delle
mean Girls alla recita di Natale ma
tesoro i tempi cambiano
e la tutina più ridicola del mondo mi
fai venire la nausea e non in senso
buono Ecco A proposito di nausea e io
ovviamente ho ricevuto la tua letterina
e Volevo giusto capire una cosa Tu hai
chiesto un alveare nuovo Perugino o chi
per sutura per mano e per la domenica di
cancro fa un tiragraffi a forma di
arcobaleno Ecco tu quindi non vuoi
niente Sei sicura Adesso che ci penso
vorrei più stalker ne ho solo uno e
questa cosa non mi mette abbastanza
ansia Spero che stia scherzando
scherzare non è il mio forte preferisco
farti morire basta Piuttosto che farti
morire dal ridere Ok vorrei anche una
macchina del caffè con all'interno una
bomba ad orologeria così in caso Tyler
tornasse a lavorare al bar gliela farei
esplodere in faccia Va bene va bene ci
penserò
Buona giornata Buon Natale devo trovare
un abito per il ballo di Natale
Ovviamente non volevo andarci ma sono in
debito con Xavier che mi ha obbligato ad
andare con lui e questa botta di
socialità mi piacciono le botte la
socialità un po' meno Ok allora ti posso
proporre Questo no questo preferirei
essere un concerto di musica pop
questo preferirei morire e non in senso
buono
questo
potrebbe andare quante volte te lo devo
dire che non voglio regali su dai aprilo
sono sicura mi piacerà
un paio di tacchi Chiunque abbia
inventato i tacchi aveva sicuramente
un'attività secondaria come torturatore
Ma dai Non ti piacciono Potresti
indossare il prossimo ballo Calcola che
quando le guardo mi vengono in mente
queste emoticon Palace corda Fossa ma
non è finita qui
un libro sugli Hide avanguardia pura
direi Peccato che per me gli Hair siano
acqua passata sono in una nuova fase
della mia vita quale
la fase stalker